[MUSIC PLAYING]
TOM MORELLO: Hello.
What's up?
Thanks for having me.
Is this thing on?
DORINA ARELLANO: Yes.
Thanks for coming.
TOM MORELLO: My pleasure.
DORINA ARELLANO: So
I wanted to start
by talking about you
being a guitarist,
because you are one of the best.
You can be humble about it.
It's OK.
TOM MORELLO: Kind of you.
DORINA ARELLANO: And you've
said that the electric guitar is
a relatively new
instrument on the planet--
TOM MORELLO: Yeah.
DORINA ARELLANO: --and
that we should not
assume that the way
it's being played so far
is the only way that
is acceptable to play.
And as someone who grew up
studying classical music,
when I hear you play, it makes
my brain crazy, in a good way.
All that non-conventional
picking, tapping,
all the guitar effects.
So how have you come up with
such interesting noises?
And how the heck do
you make a guitar
sound so cool with a pencil?
TOM MORELLO: Well, I started
playing guitar very late.
I started playing
at 17 years old
and I had never heard of
another guitar player that
made an album that started
that late, with one exception.
That was Robert Johnson.
And he had to sell his soul
at the crossroads to do that.
So I didn't want to
have to go that route,
so I thought practice might
be the other alternative.
And the best advice I ever
got as a guitar player was
from a kid in high school
who was more advanced than I.
And he said, if you want to
improve practice an hour a day
every day without fail.
And I took that as gospel.
And I found that the
rising tide of my playing
was so noticeable when I did
that, then I bumped it up
to two hours a day, and
then four hours a day.
And while I was attending
Harvard University,
I was practicing four hours
a day, 365 days a year.
And over the course
of four years,
maybe missed a day or two, due
to like traveling or something
like that.
So if I had studied till 1:00 AM
with an exam the next morning,
I would practice till
5:00, not till 4:58.
Now, this is indicative of an
obsessive compulsive disorder,
you might be gathering.
And you'd be correct about that.
But all that did was amass a
certain amount of technique
and ability that caught me up to
some other guitar players who,
at the time, were my heroes,
like the Eddie Van Halens
and Randy Rhoadses who had
a great deal of technique.
I didn't have my own
voice on the instrument.
It was around the time of
Rage Against the Machine
where I self-identified
as the DJ in the band
and began looking at the
guitar in a deconstructed way.
And that it is just
a piece of wood
with six wires and
a few electronics
that can be manipulated
in any number of ways,
and that could create sounds.
And then those sounds, even
though they're unconventional,
can be used as the
building blocks
for writing songs
and guitar solos.
So then that's when I began
practicing eight hours a day.
It was the eccentricities in my
playing and the unusual stuff.
And rather than trying to
cop Chuck Berry or Keith
Richards or Eddie Van
Halen, I would just
try to play different sounds.
And whether it was the
background music of a Public
Enemy song, or the
scratching of a DJ,
or a lawnmower outside,
or a helicopter overhead.
And just by trying it-- when you
practice that stuff, it just--
you may not be able to
sound like a lawnmower
or a helicopter,
but you're not going
to sound like Chuck Berry
or Eddie Van Halen anymore.
And so once the blinders came
off, then I had my own lane.
And I really felt like
I had found my own voice
on the instrument and the
horizons were pretty endless.
DORINA ARELLANO: So
what you're saying
is you have to work really hard.
TOM MORELLO: Well, I mean,
there was the work part
and there was the
inspiration part.
Like the work part sort of
made my fingers be able to go
where I wanted them to go.
But it was the
revelation that I did--
there was a specific
moment-- my crossroads
was at a gig in the
San Fernando Valley.
And Rage, in the
earliest days, we
were opening up for
two cover bands.
And in these cover bands--
in each of the cover
bands there was
like a really
shredding guitar player
who had tremendous
facility on the instrument.
And I thought-- I was
watching them at sound check
and I thought, if there's
two shredding guitar
players at this lousy gig in
the valley, like on a Wednesday,
there doesn't need to be three.
And so I need--
[LAUGHTER]
Like I need to figure out
something that's my own to do.
And that's when I started
practicing other stuff.
DORINA ARELLANO: So you
mentioned your guitar
influences.
Randy Rhoads, I guess you
named your son after him.
TOM MORELLO: Yeah,
Rhoads Morello.
The reason why--
Randy Rhoads was the guitar
player for Ozzie Osbourne,
for those of you who don't know.
But you sort of think it's
like a heavy metal thing.
But he's a classically
trained player
who-- he self-identified as a
musician first and as a rock
star second.
That very much appealed to me.
I grew up on like
suburban heavy metal where
the themes of the music
were often either groupies
or the devil, none of which was
present in my mom's basement
where I was practicing.
[LAUGHS] And so the
poster that was on my wall
was Randy Rhoads.
On days off from the
Ozzie Osbourne tour--
they'd be playing
arenas and stadiums,
but on days off, he'd take
classical guitar lessons
in whatever city they were in.
And I really liked that kind of
dedication to the instrument.
And that was my
aspiration as well.
DORINA ARELLANO: I
actually was just
seeing a video on YouTube,
obviously, of Ozzie
listening to the isolated
guitar solo from Crazy Train.
And unless you're
not human, you have
to get chills listening to that.
It's insane.
TOM MORELLO: It's
like it's a very emo--
the person had a
lot of technique,
but also with a classical
tangent and then a deeply sort
of emotional and kick-ass way.
DORINA ARELLANO: So powerful,
so precise, like fast.
It's crazy.
So you mentioned that Randy
actually identified himself
as a musician first.
And as much as I appreciate
good musicianship,
I grew up as a
cellist and I am sad
that I never got to jump on
stage, like AC/DC or Kiss
or whatever.
So what do you think
makes a good musician?
And what makes you
want to jump on stage?
TOM MORELLO: I can tell you
about my first stage jump.
Well, first gig I ever had, I
went to a small Illinois town.
And there were three
bands at my high school.
One of them was Destiny.
And they were beautiful men
who played beautiful music
and they were adored
by the entire school.
They were kind of like
the Beatles of the school.
Their dating lives were insane.
Then there was Epitaph.
And they were much too mean to
play at a high school dance.
And they like covered
Sabbath and AC/DC.
And you avoided them
in the hallways,
but admired them greatly.
[LAUGHS]
And then there was my band.
My band was the drama
club oriented band.
And it was called
The Electric Sheep.
And we didn't have the ability
to play other people's songs,
so we wrote our own music.
Now bizarrely, one of
the members of that band
is a fellow by name of
Adam Jones, who later
surfaced in a band called Tool.
We were in the same high
school band together.
But so our first gig, we
had auditioned for a show.
And we had to learn
the song "Born
to be Wild," which took us
four months to learn it very,
very poorly.
But we were in competition
with Destiny this night.
And they had succeeded in
their earlier performance.
So they rolled us out.
And they played like a Crosby,
Stills, Nash, and Young
song, of course.
So we were on a riser.
And the keyboard player
came in with the wrong chord
to begin the song.
Then the bass player, Adam--
who is a tremendous
musician now-- but
he came in with the
wrong note on the bass.
And things were not going great.
So I had like one
trick up my sleeve
and I could jump super high.
So I like leapt off
the riser and the roof
came off the place.
And it made me realize
that perhaps there's
more to rock and roll than
playing the right notes.
Perhaps you have to be inhabited
by the Holy Spirit of Rock
and Roll, which I felt that
maybe I had some of that in me.
And maybe that would be
my course moving forward.
DORINA ARELLANO: That's great.
So your new album, "The Atlas
Underground," just came out.
Congratulations.
TOM MORELLO: Thank
you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
DORINA ARELLANO: Yay.
So I was actually watching
one of your new music videos
on YouTube.
And the first comment was
a very excited, all caps,
EXPLICIT, which is basically
how I felt when I first
heard some of the new album.
Because there's so much--
there's all this genre
mixing going around.
You've got like EDM and hip
hop and guitar rock, obviously.
And so was that one of
your goals with the album,
to get people to listen
to kinds of music
that they don't
normally listen to?
TOM MORELLO: The goal
was a very lofty one.
And it was to forge a sonic
conspiracy of diverse artists
to shape a new genre
of rock and roll.
One that combines my
Marshall Stack riff rock
fury with big EDM drops and some
of the electronic components
of today.
In a way, a record
that serves as maybe
like a Trojan horse in 2018,
where a lot of young people
gravitate more towards
Ableton and computer
composition for music and
less practicing four, six,
eight hours a day.
And so part of my hope was to
inflict electric guitar playing
on a new generation, but working
with a really incredible cast
from Marcus Mumford to
Wu-Tang Clan, from Rise
Against to Steve Aoki,
Bassnectar, K.Flay, Vic
Mensa, Knife Party.
There's more-- Pretty Lights.
DORINA ARELLANO: Gary Clark Jr.
TOM MORELLO: Yeah,
a very eclectic mix,
but with the overall
vision of the North Star
guiding it, being to make a
new kind of rock and roll,
without compromising at
all on the guitar playing
or on the political
content, to make music that
would serve a new generation.
DORINA ARELLANO: Awesome.
And you mentioned all these
people, amazing artists
that you collaborated with.
What was the most challenging
collaboration and why?
TOM MORELLO: Well,
there's a song
called "Every Step
That I Take," which is
a collaboration with Portugal.
The Man, and Whethan,
who's a teenage wunderkind
EDM producer.
And that song I wrote with Matt
Shultz from Cage the Elephant.
And Matt got very busy,
so it took quite a while
for that to get a
final mix of that one.
But it's actually the song that
has maybe done the best out
in the world.
And we're partnering with
a great organization called
Save, which is a suicide
prevention organization,
on the song.
And my good friend Chris Cornell
passed about a year and a half
ago.
So it was very important
to get this song right
and to make this song
one that would sort of be
a fitting eulogy for him and
to provide material support
for people who are suffering
from depression or suicidal
thoughts.
DORINA ARELLANO: Yeah.
And a lot of us have or
are currently suffering
from mental illness issues.
And it's nice to
see people trying
to work to demystify that and
encourage people to get help.
So you're working with Save.
What exactly are you
hoping to do with them?
TOM MORELLO: Yeah, I mean,
part of it is the demystify
and taking the stigma
away from mental--
like if you break
your arm, you go
to the doctor to set the arm.
But if there's something
wrong in your--
something doesn't feel
right in your mind,
often even bringing it up--
the people of my parents'
generation were so--
there was a lot of depression
and things like that.
They would never touch
it with a 10-foot pole
to try to seek help.
But now hopefully, if there's
any silver lining to some
of the passings that have
happened both in people's lives
and in the
entertainment industry,
it can be to sort
of demystify that.
There is help.
And whether it's friends, loved
ones, or professional help,
or this great
organization, Save,
you can reach out to
for help at any time.
DORINA ARELLANO: And so this
song became a tribute to Chris.
TOM MORELLO: It was not
written as a tribute to Chris,
but it's been--
it's kind of pushing
it forward as a way
to make suicide
awareness something that
is at the forefront
of this record.
DORINA ARELLANO:
Just him as a talent,
can you tell us what you
learned from working with him?
TOM MORELLO: Sure.
I mean, Chris Cornell was a--
well, the thing that I learned,
in retrospect now that he's
passed, is that he was--
as a singer of Soundgarden,
and Audioslave, and then
his solo career, he had
deep, dark, personal demons,
but he managed to
harness them for 52 years
to make some of the
greatest rock and roll
that ever was made.
And so just kind of watching
that process was one to-- it
was awesome to stand next
to his rock godly self
with his incredible voice
and his incredible hair.
It's like his all vibe,
which is so perfect.
And like, you're blessed, son.
But just to be in a band--
and also, his effortless
composition of melody.
Like you give him anything, give
him a complicated heavy riff
or a simple two-chord
chord progression,
he could make it
flower into something
that was really beautiful.
DORINA ARELLANO: Are
there any other artists
that you haven't worked
with that you would
hope to work in the future?
TOM MORELLO: Yeah,
I'm actually sort
have already started on part
two of this "Atlas Underground."
There's about half
a record done.
I don't want to give
any of the names
away because it's not done yet.
But yeah, I love the idea
of challenging myself
as a guitarist and as an artist
to get outside of my safety
zone.
And the thing about
this record that--
there's two ways to
make great music.
One is a collaborative
effort with a band, where
chemistry is what's important.
And together, you're able to,
through your combined efforts,
create something that none
of you could create alone.
That's one way.
The other way is purity
of like a solo record,
where you have a vision.
Imagine sort of the
early Dylan records
or Bruce Springsteen,
where there's a unified--
like it's one person's
vision that is fulfilled,
and it's undiluted
from the outside.
What I tried is to get the best
of both worlds on this record,
where it's a--
on this record, I'm a
guitarist, I'm a songwriter,
I'm the curator,
first and foremost--
is to following both a
thematic and musical vision.
But getting the benefit
of the crossover
collaboration on
each of the tracks.
Every one of the 12 tracks
has at least one collaborator
on it.
And allowing that
chemistry to flower in ways
that were very unexpected to me.
DORINA ARELLANO: So no
spoilers yet for part two?
TOM MORELLO: No
spoilers for part two,
but there's some good metal
and some very surprising stuff
on it.
DORINA ARELLANO: So I
wanted to ask about how
music may be changing.
It's always evolving.
And when I see companies
like Gibson Guitars,
for example, going
bankrupt, do you
think that that means that
composers are moving away
from guitar and other
classic instruments
and kind of moving towards
computers, in a sense, or so?
TOM MORELLO: I would say--
DORINA ARELLANO: Because
that's what's happening.
TOM MORELLO: Yeah, almost
obviously, that's the case.
DORINA ARELLANO: So
that's why you're trying
to bring back the guitar?
TOM MORELLO: All
you have to look
is like the Spotify
charts and all that.
And you have to look really
hard to find anything that has
any guitar in it whatsoever.
I think that my theory is
that it may have something
to do with the way people
listen to music now.
And a lot of music is
listened to on a laptop
or on a phone, where two musical
elements don't sound great.
One is like distorted
guitar, and the other
is like open high hat.
So there's sort of
a tinny quality.
A fella in one of my
bands has teenage sons
who despise the rich
catalog of music
of Rage Against the
Machine and Audioslave.
And they have a
scathing review of it
that has caused me
endless sleepless nights.
They describe the music--
compared to the
music they listen to,
they describe the music of
Rage Against the Machine
and Audioslave as small music.
[OOHS FROM AUDIENCE]
Yeah.
And if you don't
understand that,
it means you're
of a certain age.
And if you do, you're like,
I see what they're saying.
But it is very interesting.
The way that music is delivered
to them, like on their phone,
Cardi B sounds huge.
But perhaps, the
"Evil Empire" record,
which was recorded
in a room 1/10
the size of the one
we're in now with a lot
of shimmery overhead,
maybe sounds different.
But anyway, like I
said, with this record,
I'm trying to take
elements of 2018,
but infuse them with a direct
injection of rock and roll
guitar playing to take back--
take the power back, literally.
DORINA ARELLANO: Yes.
Yes.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
And I mean, how
does that translate
to live performance, right?
Because I know you kind of had a
sort of art installation type--
TOM MORELLO: Yeah.
Right now, I'm doing sort
of a promo tour, which
is kind of a glorified
listening party where
we listen to the
record and then I
do some guitar demonstrations.
But in 2019, we're
putting together a tour
for the "Atlas
Underground," which
on a record that has
Wu-Tang Clan and Rise
Against and Marcus
Mumford, it's unlikely
that all 20 collaborators
will be at every show.
So the glass half full way
of looking at it is let's
make a show where you
will not miss any of them
by having the show be so
different and challenging
and immersive.
And so Sean Evans, who's
the artistic director
for Roger Waters, "The Wall,"
and the Us and Them Tours,
we're putting together a show--
it's part art installation,
part presentation of music
that will have both a
lot of guitar shredding,
but a lot of ideas in it
that will make it a really
fulfilling evening, even if
all the collaborators are not
present.
DORINA ARELLANO: Cool.
TOM MORELLO: Something
to look forward to.
DORINA ARELLANO:
Sounds exciting.
So you posted a photo on your
Instagram of your hand surgery,
which looked gross and
awesome at the same time.
TOM MORELLO: [LAUGHS]
DORINA ARELLANO: Did you
injure yourself playing,
and is there anything
inside your hand now?
TOM MORELLO: We'll just say
it was a vacation accident.
That's as much as I'm
willing to divulge.
But no, but modern
medicine is no joke.
Like I fractured the fourth
metacarpal on this hand,
which is of all the guitar
playing fingers, probably
the third most
important one, right?
And I broke in on a Thursday.
I had surgery on a
Saturday and played a show
in Stockholm, a 90-minute
set, on Tuesday.
So they just put a big old
titanium plate in there,
nailed it together.
And the doctor-- I literally
have a fist full of steel.
Like Wolverine or
something like--
It's really-- it's
like a Wolverine claw.
DORINA ARELLANO:
Adamantium, yeah.
TOM MORELLO: Yeah, adamantium,
thank you very much.
DORINA ARELLANO: Sorry, nerd.
TOM MORELLO: No, I
respect nerd-dom.
Boom, there we go.
Yeah, I'm of the Trek
village myself, so don't--
but no, it was pretty amazing.
And the doctor just
said, if you can--
you're not going to
hurt it any worse.
I'm going to nail that
thing together tight.
If you can withstand
the discomfort,
it's going to be fine.
And one thing I do have
is a good deal of will,
so the shows went pretty well.
The one thing I had to keep
reminding my bandmates,
because the shows
went so smoothly,
was what a hero I was that we
all didn't cancel the tour.
I have a broken hand and we're
playing today, all right?
[LAUGHS] I know it
looks effortless.
DORINA ARELLANO: So your
hand's more metal now.
TOM MORELLO: It is.
I am more-- I was
metal to begin with,
but I am much more metal
now than ever before.
DORINA ARELLANO: So if
you had to pick one--
Eddie Van Halen, Randy
Rhoads, or someone else?
TOM MORELLO: --or someone else.
I mean, my guy is, like for the
reason stated, is Randy Rhoads.
Like he just had that--
there was like an intelligence
to his playing and a passion
to his playing that's
kind of my number one.
DORINA ARELLANO: OK.
So with "Atlas
Underground," you seem
to be kind of pushing the
boundaries of what music can be
and what we're used
to listening to.
Are you hoping to
make a larger point
about how we maybe change
the status quo in society,
as how we see people?
It's like then it's
OK to be different.
TOM MORELLO: Sure.
Sure.
I mean, this record has
artists of diverse genres,
diverse ethnicities, diverse
ages, and diverse genders.
And that in and of
itself is a statement
in these very divisive times.
Also, the thematic thread
that runs through the record
is social justice ghost stories.
And the idea that the heroes and
martyrs and fallen of the past
can inform the
struggles of the present
and hopefully light a
beacon towards a more
just and humane future by
giving voice to the voiceless.
DORINA ARELLANO: I actually
have a question from a Googler
that couldn't be here.
He wants to know, what was a
bigger moment for you, the Cubs
World Series victory or
playing with Springsteen?
TOM MORELLO: Those are two
pretty hot moments right there.
[LAUGHTER]
I was equally nervous
for both, frankly.
I'd have to say, I
love my man The Boss,
but the Cubs thing is one
that I never thought I'd get.
That was sweet.
[LAUGHS] Though I was super--
like Bruce Springsteen
and I, we played together
over the course of six years.
And we'd been friends
for years before that.
But he's unique among my
friends in that I subscribe
to two fanzines about him.
And once chased him
down Sunset Boulevard
trying to kiss his head.
So that's like a
different lane of peer.
But playing with Bruce for
the first time in 2008,
I don't get nervous for much in
music anymore, but I was just--
I'm a huge Bruce
Springsteen fan.
And the idea of being on
stage with the E Street Band
in front of people,
and playing the song,
like with me singing with Bruce
Springsteen and playing guitar,
it was pretty crazy.
And there was a bit of a drama
on that particular night,
much like game 7 of
the 2016 World Series.
[LAUGHS] The end result was
in doubt in both of those.
Bruce had said we're going
to do "Ghost of Tom Joad."
So I learned-- he said, learn
it acoustic and electric.
So I learned the version
from his acoustic record
and was ready to play it,
felt pretty good about it.
And I heard the band rehearsing
upstairs at the Anaheim Pond
as it was called then.
And they had changed--
Bruce had changed
the key of the song.
He raised the key
about eight steps.
So now it was out of my rich,
milk chocolate, baritone frame.
And also, I couldn't
transpose the chords.
And I had to play with
the band in three minutes.
And I had to now transpose it.
And that's not my forte.
And so I was really nervous.
So I walked up there and
we're going through the song,
and I am fumbling.
I am fumbling.
I can't play the chords right.
I'm not hitting notes.
And little Steven, who's
his consigliere in the band,
and a very nice fellow, he
recognizes that I'm distraught.
He's like baby, baby, it's
going to be fine, baby.
I'm like, baby, it's not fine.
There's nothing fine
about baby right now.
Baby is super anxious.
So Bruce Springsteen, they don't
call him the boss for nothing.
He recognizes what's
going on, my anxiety.
He puts his hand on my
shoulder, looks me in the eyes
and says, Tommy--
first of all, Bruce
Springsteen calls me
Tommy, which is so dope.
Tommy, we're going
to do it in this key
and it's going to be great.
I said, well, that's easy
for you to say Obi-Wan, but--
[LAUGHS]
But at the end of the
day, I thought, well,
can I sing a song
of social justice?
Yes, I can.
Can I play a
kick-ass guitar solo?
Yes, I can.
Are there 14 people
in the E Street
Band who already
know the chords?
Yes, there are.
So I'm not going to
worry about that part.
So I went downstairs,
made my way through half
a bottle of Jameson, came up and
we blew the roof off the place.
[LAUGHS] And Obi-Wan was right.
We played in that key
and it did turn out
great the end of the day.
DORINA ARELLANO: Obi-Bruce.
So Rage is nominated for the
Rock and Roll Hall of Fame.
TOM MORELLO: So they tell me.
DORINA ARELLANO: And I
worked in the music industry,
and I still don't
know how it works.
And you're on the
committee, so can you
explain to us how it works?
And did you nominate yourself?
TOM MORELLO: [LAUGHS]
First of all,
much like when they
choose the Pope,
there's no divulging how it
actually works in the room.
But there's a
committee that fights
passionately for the artists
that they put forward.
I did not put forward
Rage Against the Machine,
but I was pleased
that someone else did.
And then you fight for--
you advocate for yours.
And there's a lot of voting.
And it's like a sort of
Byzantine voting scheme,
that eventually we wind up with
a ballot of 15 names, which
is the one that was
announced the other day.
And then it goes to a wider
votership of about 800 or 900.
And then five or six get in.
The thing that's great about
the Rock-- first of all,
I was an opponent of the
Rock and Roll Hall of Fame.
As a kid, I grew up
playing baseball.
And when you're in your
first year of t-ball,
you dream of one day
having a career that
would be great enough that
you could enter the Baseball
Hall of Fame.
And as a guitar player,
as a rock guitar player,
I thought the Rock
and Roll Hall of Fame
didn't have any of my
favorite bands in it.
Like why would I
want to be in that?
It doesn't have
anybody I like in it.
So Jon Landau, who's Bruce
Springsteen's manager,
and I spent a lot of
time on tour with him,
I relentlessly pounded him
about how the Rock and Roll
Hall of Fame stunk.
And I'm like, it
doesn't represent
an entire genre of music.
And to his credit,
he heard my pleas
and he let me in the room.
And since then, a number of
bands, including Stevie Ray
Vaughan and Rush
and Kiss that were
very deserving of being in
the Rock and Roll Hall of Fame
have gotten in.
And others have been nominated,
like Judas Priest and whatever.
But anyway, it's taken a
step in the right direction.
And now I think that
anybody who does pick up
a guitar with aspirations
of being a rock guitarist
can be proud to be
nominated for the Rock Hall.
DORINA ARELLANO: And I
mean, it's similar to the,
I guess, any sort of music
award show, like the Grammys.
Like they don't seem to
nominate a lot of metal bands.
And I'm a metal fan.
So thank you for doing that.
TOM MORELLO: I'm doing my best.
DORINA ARELLANO: Can you think
about your best and worst
performances?
TOM MORELLO: Sure.
The worst performance is
pretty-- there's been a few--
but the worse performance
comes to mind immediately.
Rage Against the Machine was
ascendant in 1993 or '94.
And we were playing the
Reading Festival in England.
It was our first time
jumping from club shows to--
we weren't headlining.
We were playing later in the
day in front of 60,000 people.
And our music in England at
the time was like on fire.
And so there was a great
deal of expectation.
And I'd worked out a new
guitar redefining trick
on the guitar, where I take
out the jack of the guitar
and then I tap it to
the metal on the guitar
and it makes like a noise.
And then I manipulate it.
And it's like minds
are going to be blown.
And our Reading
performance is going
to be broadcast, not just
all over England, but all
over Europe.
It's like the Rage Against
the Machine hour, right?
And I'm ready for my
moment during the solo
in "Bullet in the Head."
And the TV camera zooms
in and I unplug the jack.
Now, what I don't realize
is that the power--
what makes an amp--
it's some grounding
that makes the steel jack
go [BUZZ NOISE] like this.
But the power in England
is different than the power
in the United States.
So while I've been blowing minds
all over the United States--
there was no sound
check for these shows.
You just show up and play.
So with cocky confidence, I
walk to the front of the stage
as the camera zooms in for
my heroic guitar redefining
moment.
I unplug the jack, I touch
it to the thing, it goes ptt.
[LAUGHTER]
Ptt.
The camera is getting closer,
like maybe it's still coming.
I'm like ptt.
And then I just sheepishly
plug the guitar back in, take
a few steps back, and play a
couple of Chuck Berry licks.
[LAUGHS] That wasn't my best--
that wasn't the best one.
That wasn't the best one.
I've had a lot of really,
really great moments on stage.
One of them was like when
Rage Against the Machine
played in Finsbury Park in 2010.
Somehow there had been
this Facebook campaign
to make a 17-year-old Rage
Against the Machine song number
one on the pop charts.
It was up against Simon
Cowell's "X Factor."
I won't go into detail.
But it's like every
year at Christmas,
the "X Factor" in England,
Simon Cowell's show,
has the number one song.
And in England it matters.
They gamble on the
number one song
like they do on
the Kentucky Derby.
It's a huge deal.
And everyone on
Christmas morning
sits down and listens
to the top 10.
And the number one
is celebrated wildly.
And every year for the
last five or six years,
it had been the
winner of the TV show
"The X Factor" sang some
syrupy, horrible song.
And that was guaranteed
to be the number
one because it was
promoted widely
by Sony and everything else.
So a couple in suburban
London was sick of it
and they started a
Facebook campaign
to make Rage Against
the Machine's "Killing
in the Name," to
put that forward,
a 17-year-old song with 16 FU's
and one mother flipper in it.
And without the band's
involvement in any way,
soon the Facebook campaign
had 500,000 people on it.
And it was huge.
And we were just going about
our lives, kind of not even
being a band.
And we heard about
it and we decided
to get involved at
the last minute.
And we played-- we
were on whatever
the "Good Morning
America" of Britain was.
And they said, whatever you
do, when you perform the song,
don't do the cussing part.
And we thought, the cussing
part of the song is fuck you,
I won't do what you tell me.
[LAUGHTER]
So sure, we won't do it.
So like the "Good
Morning America,"
it's the big special
for the Christmas thing.
And we go on and
we play the song.
And there's like-- I don't
know if you're familiar.
It was sort of like
the quiet fuck you
part, which is like
kind of whispered,
and then the big fuck you part.
And so the quiet part,
Zach doesn't do it at all.
And the sensors
are like relaxing.
And then it comes, he just
tells England, fuck you,
I won't do what you tell me.
And of course, that
helped spike sales.
[LAUGHS] And we had the
number one pop single.
It was the most downloads in a
week in the history of the UK.
And we defeated the--
one of things we promised to
the fans there was if we did
have the number one song,
we would play a free concert
for all of England.
So they wouldn't let
us in the nicer parks
around London, [LAUGHS] because
it was a bit of a reputation.
And so Finsbury Park
is where we had it.
It was cordoned off for 45,000.
Another 45,000 jumped the fence.
There were almost
100,000 people.
We played a free show.
And we finished the night
playing "Killing in the Name."
And it was just like
a beautiful night of--
it really was like the
manifestation of the band's
ideals came to fruition.
It was not the band that did it.
It was fans that really
took the power back in a way
that-- in some ways, it's
just a number one single.
But it demonstrated that by
standing up in your place
and time for something
you believe in,
you can overcome great odds.
DORINA ARELLANO: That is great.
Thank you so much
for sharing that.
So good.
[APPLAUSE]
So I'm going to ask
you one more question,
but then we're going to
open up audience questions.
So please think
of some good ones.
Don't embarrass us.
So you mentioned you're
doing a sort of part two.
Is this-- are you doing another
album that you're collaborating
or what's in the future for you?
TOM MORELLO: Yeah,
another record
of diverse collaborations
that continues
to try to push my guitar playing
and musical artistry further.
In the same genre
of taking artists
that I admire in unusual
combinations and making music
that's very challenging and
exciting, but is guitar-based.
DORINA ARELLANO: Cool.
Looking forward to it.
So who wants to go first?
So we have this--
hello.
Is this is working?
I'm going to throw this at you.
What was it, you?
TOM MORELLO: That is such a
Google invention right there.
[LAUGHS] That is full Google.
AUDIENCE: I was wondering what
music you're listening to now.
What's on your playlist?
TOM MORELLO: Oh,
that's a good question.
I love The Interrupters
now, which is a great ska
band on Tim Armstrong's label.
I listen to a lot of music
in the car with my kids,
and so it jerks wildly between
Metallica's "Master of Puppets"
and the "Hamilton" soundtrack.
[LAUGHTER]
With a good deal of clean
version Cardi B thrown in.
That's what I'm-- [LAUGHS].
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
DORINA ARELLANO: Who's next?
Oh, right there.
AUDIENCE: So I'm
a huge fan of Rage
Against the Machine's music.
I love metal music.
I also love electronic music.
And I tune in to watch the
Ultra Music Festival that's
live streamed every year.
So one of my favorite
groups, Knife Party,
when they close out their
set and bring you out
to this gigantic crowd to wow
them with this explosive guitar
playing overlay with
dubstep and this crazy kind
of electronic music, how'd
that feel for the first time?
TOM MORELLO: Yeah, that was--
I mean, that was
really the first--
I was an enemy of EDM music.
I thought it was--
I knew it only as
Italian taxicab music,
or like Ibiza yacht awfulness.
Until a metal friend turned
me on to Knife Party,
who is in the EDM genre.
But I felt the same aggression
and tension and release
as in my favorite rock and roll.
They were the first people
that I reached out to and said,
I have an idea.
What if you do
what you do and we
replace some of
your synthesizers
with my electric guitar?
The idea being if
my electric guitar
is the Ansel Adams clear
black and white photo,
I want to hear the smashed
Picasso version, something
that's recognizable,
but you hear it
in an entirely different way.
So standing at Ultra
Festival, which
is like 135,000
16-year-olds who are wasted,
right, [LAUGHS] wearing
nothing but glowsticks.
That's what it is.
It's in Miami.
It's insane.
Which is my usual
audience, right?
So I go out on
stage to play this--
it's the collaborated
song "Battle Sirens,"
which is on this new record,
but we wrote it some years ago.
That was like maybe
two or three years ago.
And so I go out on stage
and I'm ready to rock,
and then I would notice that
their crew, as an EDM crew,
they've never mic'd
an amplifier before.
So there's no mic on my amp.
So there's like a PA system
ready to not hear me.
And I'm headed towards like
another ptt moment, right?
So fortunately, at
the last minute,
they did put a mic on it.
And if you check
that on YouTube,
it's a really awesome
moment in collaboration.
That really made me think that
there was something in this.
So thanks for being there.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so
much for the answer.
TOM MORELLO: Sure.
Sure.
AUDIENCE: I've been a big fan
of Rage Against the Machine,
I would say, for a
long time as well.
Seeing as you're so interested
in unusual sounds and things
like that, and a lot
of rock musicians
have moved in this
direction, have you ever
been interested in doing film
music or television music?
TOM MORELLO: I've done a
lot of film in the past.
I did the rock score for
two of the "Iron Man" movies
and have appeared on a number
of soundtracks and scores.
One of things that I--
I did a couple of Michael
Mann movies as well.
And while it's a--
I like it in theory
better than in practice.
Because one thing when
you do music scoring,
you have something that you
don't have when you're a band.
And that is, you have a boss.
Then you have someone who
wants to hear it sadder.
And like, what do
you mean sadder?
[LAUGHS] You have these
sort of directorial geniuses
who do not have the
musical vocabulary
to help to guide you.
I forget what it was.
I did a score for a movie
that I don't know if I ever
saw it at the end of the day.
But it was for "A Team."
It was like the Mr. T reboot.
Anyway.
And so we spent so
much time on that.
It needed to be cut-- it
was this 12-minute sequence
and it needed to be
everything completely spot on.
And they'd send me the
vaguest directions back.
It needs to sound
more like it's played
on an oasis in the
middle of an atoll.
And I'm like, OK, we'll
get right on that, yeah.
So just like turn
the bass up a little?
Is that-- I don't know.
[LAUGHS]
So finally, we made it sound
like the atoll [INAUDIBLE]..
And so the movie comes out,
and when I see the movie,
they've taken this 12 and
1/2 minute musical piece that
was meticulously
tailored to the film,
and they just put it in an
entirely different scene.
[LAUGHS] Just like intact,
just in a different scene.
I'm like, I guess the
atoll music goes there.
Anyway.
I'm open to it, but
I'm not seeking it out.
Any other questions?
There's a couple up from
here, one back there.
AUDIENCE: So in high
school, I remember
there was this year or two where
these really pivotal albums
came out--
"Nevermind," "Ten,"
Rage's self-titled,
"Badmotorfinger," all of these.
Can you talk a little
bit about how much you
were trying to change music
in that era versus like--
TOM MORELLO: Sure.
I think that it had less to
do with trying to change music
and that the music
industry had a revelation
with the "Nevermind" record,
and maybe the Pearl Jam "Ten"
record, that they
didn't know best what
was connecting with audiences.
And they stepped back from the
over A&R-ing and trying to mold
artists into stars and going,
we don't understand Tool
or Nirvana, or Rage
or Nine Inch Nails.
But whatever they're
doing is connecting,
so step back from it.
I was in a band before
Rage Against the Machine
called Lock Up, which was kind
of like a Living Color style
funk rock band.
And we got a record
deal, which was--
I had never met a person that
had a record deal before.
And so we were
very, very excited.
And we did everything that
everyone asked us to do.
Like the A&R person
made these suggestion.
The producer dampened
down some of the weirder
parts of my guitar play.
I'm like, well, I
guess they know best.
This band Lockup also had
probably the worst album title
in the history of Western music.
I'll share it with you now.
The record was called "Something
Bitchin' This Way Comes."
And yes, that's bitchin'
with an apostrophe.
[LAUGHTER] So we weren't
off to a strong start.
But that band was
summarily dropped,
and all the cliches that
happen, the dickings that happen
to bands happened to that band.
And at 27 years old, I was done.
I had my grab at
the brass ring and I
had failed to be an album
maker or a rock star.
So I made a vow to myself
that I'm never going to play--
that's not going to happen.
I'm never going to play
another note of music
that I don't believe in.
And that's when
I started writing
the riffs for the first Rage
Against the Machine Record.
And was very surprised--
like that was a band--
there no radio station or record
store or club in Hollywood
that was booking a neo-Marxist,
multi-ethnic, punk, rap, metal
band.
And we made those songs in a
complete vacuum of ambition.
And we just made songs that
we loved and believed in.
And then, much to
our surprise, that
was what connected
with a global audience.
But there's a lesson in there
that's very thinly veiled.
DORINA ARELLANO: Can you please
call your next album "Something
Bitchin' This Way Comes?"
TOM MORELLO: Oh, geez.
[LAUGHTER]
It's already there.
AUDIENCE: A first shout out.
I'm from Chicago
suburbs as well.
I saw rage at
Lollapalooza three.
TOM MORELLO: Which suburb?
AUDIENCE: Darien.
Yeah, [INAUDIBLE].
So my question is, what
is with the hippo pegasus?
TOM MORELLO: Well,
the image is one
that feels to me like it's
as a gravitas and a weight
and a power to it.
It also has a beauty to it.
And it's a combination
of unexpected elements.
And all those three things
I see as representing
the music on the record.
I also have loved
hippos since I was a kid
and went to the Brookfield Zoo.
You know what that is.
AUDIENCE: Damn right.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Hey, Tom.
Thanks for finding the
time to be here today.
TOM MORELLO: Sure.
AUDIENCE: So I'm a
singer from Ukraine.
I've been doing rock and metal.
And I had a cover band when
we did "Killing in the Name
Of," but Ukrainian audience know
English enough to ask us not
to do that anymore in the pubs.
[LAUGHTER]
So I have two questions.
Basically, we just
moved a year ago.
I'm just learning
the business here.
And I have a full
time job, obviously.
So I have a budget
of five hours a week
and I'm trying to choose
between basically getting
better, the songwriting, and
building a brand on YouTube.
So how would you balance that?
TOM MORELLO: Well, I would
say, first of all, welcome.
And one thing
that's sort of crazy
is how many metal dudes
there are at Google,
and women are at Google.
That's pretty interest.
That's was a little bit
surprising, in an awesome way.
No wonder it's such
a successful company.
[LAUGHS]
And the first thing
I would say is
that the rules of how music
is made and distributed
in the world are so
radically different from when
I moved to Hollywood in 1986,
that my kids' babysitter's
boyfriend is a YouTube star.
And I just don't have
any understanding of even
what he does.
I don't know-- [LAUGHS] I have
no idea what that dude does.
So maybe that's the best route.
But I would say, my
recommendation to you
is in order to be
a-- it's very, very
easy to be a success
by a certain criteria.
And that is, if you play and
write music that you love
and that you enjoy, whether
or not there's an audience,
you will have an artistic
satisfaction that is--
let me tell you,
there are people
who are playing stadiums
that don't have that.
And they do not
sleep well at night.
I know them, and that's true.
But then there are people
who jam in their basements
on the weekend with
friends that have
a fulfillment via music that is
what music is really all about.
So the path to success in
2018 I can't counsel you
on because I really don't know.
But the path to having fun and
a very meaningful experience
with music is one I would say,
write songs that you believe in
and play guitar--
or play songs that
you really love
and enjoy it to its fullest.
AUDIENCE: Quick question-- what
was the first effects pedal
or processor that got you
going with experimenting?
TOM MORELLO: Yeah, yeah.
I remember walking to
the Highland Park music
store when I could
afford an effects pedal.
And I turned on the delay
pedal and had like--
I just turned every
knob all the way up.
And it sounded so super freaky.
I'm like, that's the
most awesome thing.
That's what most
guitar players do
is when you get a guitar pedal,
you think that's awesome.
And then you dampen it, like
you make it more subtle.
And you go for like, oh,
I want to just nuance
this, that, and the other.
And I never lost that feeling
of let's do the crazy thing
and try to experience
that same--
to make people's ears freak
out like I did when I first
turned that effects pedal on.
In my setup, it's a
very limited number--
I've embraced limitations
with regards to the equipment.
I have the same four or five
effects pedals, some of which
I bought at that-- that effects
pedal may be in the running
there as an alternate.
But my idea was to take a very
limited amount of gear and--
because I never
liked the sound--
when I first got
my first check--
I was working for a
United States senator.
I got my first check.
And I went to a guitar
shop in Hollywood.
And they custom made
a guitar for me.
And I didn't know anything
about which fretboards--
so it was a stinker.
It was like an expensive,
horrible guitar.
And over the course
of some years,
I replaced every bit of the
electronics and the neck.
And I never got it to sound
like the sound I had in my head.
And so one Lockup rehearsal,
I was fed up with it
and I took this amp
that I had and I--
this is as good as
I can make it sound.
I am unfulfilled
with this sound.
I marked the settings on it.
But I'm never going to
think about it again.
Because I felt so much
of my creative time
was being expended
chasing a tone.
And I thought, this is
just going to be my sound.
And now I'm going
to write song--
I'm going to create with this.
The markings on that amp-- it's
the amp that I used at the show
last night--
they haven't changed since 1988.
Every song I've ever
recorded, every song I've ever
played live, is with--
many of those songs-- with
that guitar that I didn't feel
fulfilled with and with
those amp settings.
And one more sort of lesson to
draw, Rage Against the Machine,
we were practicing for
a South American tour.
And we had to do
it on rental gear.
And we were playing
our normal Rage songs,
but on not our own gear.
And it sounded bad.
And so Brad, the
drummer, said to me,
are we really so dependent
on our gear to sound good?
And I thought, that's possible,
but it's also possible
that if we had started
with this gear,
we would have written
songs that sounded great
with these sounds.
And so I think that just
not worrying so much
about what the tone
is and worrying
about what your
creativity can be
is what would be
my recommendation.
AUDIENCE: Cool, thank you.
TOM MORELLO: You're welcome.
DORINA ARELLANO: One more.
AUDIENCE: I think
it's back to Ukraine.
DORINA ARELLANO: Oh, you may
get to ask your last question.
There you go.
TOM MORELLO: The
Ukrainian delegation.
AUDIENCE: So I'm doing a
lot of open mics right now.
So what is the next--
I know it's hard for
you to remember maybe,
but what is the next
level after open mics
but before actual thousand--
TOM MORELLO: Sure.
First of all, I think
open mics are great.
In the height of
Audioslave's fame,
I was doing open mic nights.
I made four records under the
name The Nightwatchman, which
is like an acoustic folk
troubadour, political kind
of Woody Guthrie,
Phil Ochs thing.
And on days off, I would
go and do open mic nights.
And again, in those
experiences, I
found playing three songs
with a latte blender
whirring in the background
was really fulfilling.
It was like I was communicating.
And it was playing stuff
that I felt was true.
And I was fighting
for my artistic soul
in these coffeehouses.
So there's nothing
wrong with just
playing the open mic nights.
I would say, if you want to
go beyond that, a key way
to get better--
two ways to get better are to
play live, which you're doing,
and to play with other people.
That's a crucial
component is to--
whether they're better than you,
whether they're worse than you,
just the chemistry
that you get and
the collaborative experience is
one that will probably be fun
and you will
certainly learn from,
and will improve
your own playing.
DORINA ARELLANO:
Well, everyone, check
out "The Atlas Underground."
It is out now.
Thank you so much
for being here, Tom.
TOM MORELLO: Thanks very much,
and your thoughtful questions.
[APPLAUSE]